all right
chat is already hopping
we got jenna we got joel we got nightly
nerd in here as well
josh keaton josh what's up welcome
uh let's see i gotta give uh there was
one person i definitely gotta make sure
i shout out this person because they
said
uh let's see careless dreamer there we
go looks like i'll be able to join chad
today
we got jason ingram here we got dylan
here
we got rick we got colin
all right there we go
people of the internet welcome to retro
rack and tour live we got keegan
we got
uh zandras
that's the thing man like some of the
names i'm sure i'm botching them
terribly feathers mcgraw now that i love
that name right there
jai circo
tristan is here thomas is here as well
thomas says finally gets to
check out a live stream we got galla
free
cw evans what's up cw dude cw always
showing love on twitter
appreciate it appreciate it we got ezra
we got elizabeth we got justice jesse
otter p.o.p
welcome welcome welcome
can't wait for this game to drop bj says
hit that like button that's right so
radical
hit that like button give it a thumbs up
if you're enjoying the video
uh my day's been been going pretty well
so far thanks for asking yeah
it's uh
it's kind of been a crazy news cycle for
hogwarts legacy right the past couple
days
past couple uh i don't know like two
weeks or so it's been pretty interesting
so we're gonna break it all down tonight
i really want to dive in i'm so glad i
started these live streams when i did
because as you all
if you're checking out this live stream
you've probably already seen the
autodesk presentation or at least you've
read breakdowns of it
but when you make a youtube video like
that it's like oh man there's there's so
much to cover there was way more to
cover than i expected i can't lie
i was not expecting it in fact i had it
on my radar but it wasn't like
it wasn't something that i felt like i
really needed to make sure that i set
aside time for
screen capped it
shout out to expecto go james for
helping me out hooking me up with that
because after the fact it was like oh
wow oh oh oh they're showing this oh
oh we get a new cutscene too
um which i you know i don't blame
chandler for downplaying it because it
was a much more technical kind of
showcase
but all that being said like for a
youtube video i gotta get to the point
right i mean i gotta i gotta pick out
three to five of the biggest things hit
on those things quickly
and then maybe we do another video i've
actually considered doing another video
breaking it down even further but the
thing i love about the live streams is
that
it's when and everything doesn't need to
be as polished it doesn't need to be as
highly edited we could just go through
it
why i don't know actually that's a good
question i don't know if we can watch it
all or not but we're gonna i'm gonna
show some screenshots and stuff
and we're gonna talk through it because
there were so many things that i did not
get to include
in my video
so
1am for a gala free 2 a.m for knx
piorette no no piarettes yet i got to
meet up with um
i got to meet up with james at some
point we gotta have like a hogwarts
legacy
gathering
and all of us are just gonna i mean he's
gonna teach us live
i feel like that's the only way you know
first house i'm going to pick uh
definitely gryffindor definitely
gryffindor let me show you guys
something uh
some of you have probably seen the uh
the little icons in the chat so
uh if you're a youtube member you get
these icons so dylan was posting them
earlier i think i saw jason posting some
as well
and then uh there was one more nico yeah
nico's here too so let me show you guys
this because i'm pretty pumped about
this
[Music]
oh no that is that is definitely not
what i wanted you guys to see
how about that
there we go
so i'm actually working on some
wallpapers that i'm going to release
for free
so i'll probably put these out on
twitter or something but i was like man
i want to put these on shirts i want to
put these on
i saw somebody had a
i think it was the slytherin
somebody had the slytherin one set as
their twitter profile i was like that's
pretty awesome dude
that's pretty awesome
so
we got this one here is uh i actually
have this set as my wallpaper right now
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
release a version of each house and
this'll like like i said it's it's gonna
i'm gonna put them out for free probably
on my twitter i just gotta package
everything together so there'll be one
like this where you can have all of them
and then i'm gonna have one that's like
just the so the line will be in the
middle and then the whole rest of it
will be this kind of maroon so very
simplistic i'm kind of toying around
with the idea of like taking the lion
and then putting a bunch of them and
sort of fading them out like doing a
little opacity and then the one in the
middle is like the bold one but we'll
see i'm still kind of playing around
with it and then i'm going to release
them like for phone wallpaper sizes as
well so for each house
oh wait i forgot to uh
there we go you guys can't see me
it's all good i don't use this scene
very much this is my gameplay scene so
if we ever do any live streams with
games
this is the scene i'll use so you got
the main game can obviously be in the
background
ben snow expect to go podcast now
yes we we have tried um
i'm actually going to be on with alex
tomorrow
alex is doing a live a live stream as
well i think off to double check the
time i think it's around like 8 8 30 so
kind of the same time as this right now
he's already had james on he had um
benjamin snow on as well and i think
he's i think he's got several lined up
but we
we had initially
alex reached out way back
and we all we all definitely want to do
like a joint thing
um most of us have uh families and kids
a lot of us have kids as well so it's
it's a challenge to get all of us
on at the same time but we are we are
going to try
to do it at least once at least once
before
hogwarts legacy launches
love the art yeah dude shout out to
lex let me get the exact handle because
if you guys are needing any kind of
artwork done at all
this is crazy dude so lex a lex so
l-e-x-e-h-l-e-x
on twitter if you need any kind of
artwork done
hit him up on twitter because he uh he's
a hufflepuff
and i just put out a a call on twitter
one day because i i was like i want to
do some artwork i want to do i want to
update the emotes for the channel
and i want to get some ideas for like
t-shirts
oh man
oh
i've teased some of these but let me let
me show you guys one more thing
because i just like i'm so excited about
these
that i got i gotta show you i gotta show
you just a couple more things
but um i was like yeah let's do some
t-shirts let's do some like wallpapers
and icons
and
i just put it out on twitter which may
or may not have been a it worked out but
i just got bombarded with a lot of uh
bots
tons of bots i looked around on fiverr
first didn't really find i wanted to
find somebody who was a fan somebody who
was an artist who was a fan of harry
potter
and that was really the only criteria i
mean bonus points if you were a fan of
the channel well it turned out that he
is a fan of the channel he's a fan of
harry potter and he's a super good
amazing artist as well
so
i kind of ran some ideas by him
and we had very little revisions at all
so i've got i've got all these that you
see here i'm gonna be doing some sort of
shirt for each one of those that we're
gonna put out on uh
the teespring store which right now it's
just like logo stuff but eventually
so let me go
okay here's shirts
so this is one of the designs you guys
this is one of them this is probably the
one that i'm i'm most excited about
i mean he absolutely crushed it with
this one
crushed it and see you gotta be i mean
with this kind of stuff like if i'm
gonna sell if it's gonna be sold as my
merch well obviously it's not it's not
harry potter merch guys it's not harry
potter
so we're like okay let's stick to well
for the houses we can do animals right
you can do houses you can use the colors
so that's what we did they're not it's
not a
this is not a gryffindor badge here it's
a lion badge
then like this one right here i mean
i was like we got to do something with
merlin we got to do something with
merlin
and so this is what he came up with and
i don't think i think this was the very
first
we might have like chain i might have
had a revision on the text or something
but this was first draft this was just
me saying like dude we got to do
something with merlin we came very close
shout out to james again expect to go we
came so close to making this heir of
merlin
instead
but i was like ooh
i said let's go with order of merlin
because that one i feel a little more
secure you know if i do air of merlin
and then the game comes out and we're
not like we're not related to merlin at
all
merlin's army yeah we
could have done something merlin's army
but i was like order of merlin that's
all that's that's perfect so i'm working
on getting this mocked up for a shirt so
that's going to be coming soon um as
well but yeah then there are let's see
how many other designs do we have
we've got two other
shirt designs as well that i'm gonna
gradually release
uh there's gonna be i'm not gonna show
these guys to yet we gotta keep
something secret
gotta keep something secret but i will
tell you what they are one is for the
unforgivable curses
which i did a poll on youtube and that
was like the top result
like my goodness every time i do
anything dark arts unforgivable curses
it always does super well
you guys all the comments are always
like man i can't wait to just walk
around hogwarts avada kedavra everything
like dude you guys are freaking me out
so this is not a shirt i will ever wear
the one with the unforgivables
which
may speak to how creepy it is but for
the people who really want the
unforgivable one i think they will dig
it the other one is going to be a um
wizards chess club one
so
that was one that did did well in the
poll too i didn't even plan on talking
about this i just realized i had these
set as my desktop wallpaper and i'm like
okay
we might as well talk about this for a
bit mary studios want that shirt now
as soon as james saw it he's like oh my
gosh dude you know i uh you know i want
that
amir what's up amir looks like we have
some some new people who have joined
looks like everybody's loving the uh
the hufflepuff you love the uh
the merlin one
how many play oh that's that's a really
good question
high one two three how many play
throughs
i mean for sure
like minimum of two i feel like you
gotta start with two to do the good and
the bad right you gotta you gotta go all
in on the good you gotta go all in on
the bad
and then
then depending on how different it is
like for the houses and stuff
we'll see maybe more maybe more i mean
for content there's no telling how many
times i'm gonna have to play through it
why is it showing that one i want you to
show
oh it's showing my dude that is like
trippy right
we're looking into an endless tunnel
there
uh let me add the right
window capture here
hey thanks mark appreciate it
ravenclaw's for life mr meow i'm trying
to get expelled dude that's like in the
comments that's the way i feel
i feel like every everybody's like
they're wanting to go all out on how uh
how evil can they be
jay saw the post on twitter aj thank you
for stopping by welcome
retro wrecking tour collect tradition
with this shirt included well i have
heard
i've heard they're planning merch that's
not like a
concrete thing that's just like some
rumblings i have heard
is that they there will be some sort of
like official hogwarts legacy merch but
that's kind of weird too right because
if you think about it a lot of it i mean
it's set in the wizarding world we kind
of already have official merch in terms
of the houses and things like that but
maybe they're planning some very
specific specific things
rick wants the evil shirt day one
i'm telling you dude the unforgivables
people are super excited for the
unforgivables
okay well that i mean now we're just
like we're way in the portal again right
there
why why is it showing that screen i
don't understand
let's see display capture
there we go that's the one
that's the one we need
all right now we just got to resize it
so you guys can see all of them
should you change your youtube username
to your real name or keep it as it is i
mean it's up to you some people don't
really like using their real names on uh
online it took me a very long time to
come up with retrorecontour let me tell
you
a very long time plan on doing the
anti-hero type
there is no good slytherin just evil
if you get expelled that's game over
yeah it's gonna be really interesting to
see how they handle that it really is
because um
the more i think about it i just don't
think we're gonna be using avada kadavra
freely i really don't
i think it'll be much more of kind of a
well they talked about finishers right i
think it's going to be a finisher and
probably a late game finisher
hopefully not disappointing you guys
evil descendant of merlin would be kind
of interesting i mean merlin was a
slytherin you know
which again doesn't automatically mean
evil
neutral and used curses yeah that's like
that's the other thing
i'm working on a video now about that
curse barkley about
i wonder how they're going to handle
spells based on which path you choose
because in the harry potter world if you
think about like quote unquote dark
magic
dark magic is really anything that
causes harm
to another being or creature
it's how the hp wiki defines it well i'm
like well in that case i mean
we see in the trailer they're like
roasts with incendio
burning these people alive you know i
mean well that's that's kind of dark
magic you know but incendio as a spell
isn't necessarily dark magic so
anybody should be able to use incendio
but maybe if you like use it to burn
someone then like you're uh if there's
like a good evil meter your meter kind
of uh it moves more towards the evil if
you do that but i feel like for the
unforgivables
will they have it open for anybody to
use
or will it be like no you have to choose
that path
shadow hey first time stopping by for a
live stream welcome
used to go online as a character name
went on an mmo until i realized that i
want to do other content chose you my
first name but on my list
yeah i've toyed around with the idea of
eventually changing it
but now like i feel like retro rack and
tour just kind of stuck and so if i ever
if i ever made a
another channel that was like focused on
i don't know like how to grow on youtube
or
tech help or anything like that i think
i would use my real name
but yeah that's actually a big question
if you're not making content just leave
it whatever you know whatever you think
sounds cool
all right so let's uh i want to pull up
some of these
let me turn down the music just a bit or
actually i think it's not too loud for
you guys i just need to turn it down on
my my end here
i want to go through
some of the latest hogwarts legacy news
and so for starters since i've already
seen some of you asking about
the delay rumors uh and that sort of
thing
i'll tell you what i posted
but first i want to go over what sort of
reignited this recently so here's
the article right here
so this is by paul tassie contributor
for uh forbes he does a lot of stuff
with gaming so
i mean paul tassie knows
knows the gaming space for sure
i mean sometimes he gets it wrong but he
definitely knows the space that's my
point
so here's the title of the article and
this just released earlier today
a lack of a hogwarts legacy release date
this late raises questions so i think we
could all agree with that right there's
no denying that this this late in the
year it's gonna raise questions which is
why we do these live streams we ask lots
of questions
so here here we go we're just gonna go
through this here it's really it's not a
long article at all actually so we can
we can read the whole thing so yesterday
everyone was somewhat caught off guard
by the news that marvel midnight suns
will be delayed out of 2022 and now
feature a staggered release with the
next gen versions arriving in fiscal
year 2023 but no dates on last gen
versions yet
and then here's what is kind of the
insane part of this we were just two
months away from what appeared to be a
fixed
october 9th release date
and it's clear that current calendar we
have for fall holiday releases may not
be as firm as initially thought at least
for some games i think that that piece
right there is why this is such a big
story
i mean this kind of came
whoops didn't mean to do that
oh that's ign's article on the delay
though
um
i mean
i don't cover uh all games as much as
like uh alex from podcast now we'll
probably talk about this a little bit
tomorrow see to get his insight because
i hadn't really been following marvel
midnight sons that closely but from what
i had heard
like tassie says here i mean it seemed
to be a relatively
stable release it seemed to be expected
you know
uh there was not a plan
i don't think people were thinking there
was a delay they had announced october
9th release date so that's why this was
kind of like oh wow
this close i mean we're august
we are august what today was august 9th
so it was exactly two months before it
was supposed to release
that's crazy
moving on here out of all the major
releases this holiday and there are
shrinkingly few there's only one that
continues to stand out to me is
something that may end up delayed out of
this year
not god of war ragnarok
definitely not modern warfare 2 or
pokemon
but rather i keep coming back to
hogwarts legacy the sprawling harry
potter rpg okay first let's talk about
the good news
the fact that people are talking about
hogwarts legacy in the category with god
of war modern warfare 2 and pokemon i
mean those my gosh like those are three
heavy hitters you guys
heavy hitters right there
and hogwarts legacy is up there in terms
of
the type of buzz it's gonna it's gonna
generate and hopefully sales
um but i agree with him here like
god of war they just announced their
release date they seem like they're
definitely moving toward that modern
warfare two pokemon
nintendo and uh
who's is it infinity ward for this
modern warfare yeah i mean those the
moderate the call of duty games it's
like clockwork it's like clockwork right
and so he says but i keep coming back to
hogwarts like it's sprawling harry
potter rpg why hogwarts psychosis a few
reasons first the scale of the game
seems incredibly ambitious from what we
have seen so far and even though
technically it already slid from 2021 to
2022 it would not be unusual for a game
this big to move even further back
especially given how much is riding on
this one for wb and the beleaguered
harry potter brand um i agree with about
95 of this
yo
a seer a thank you for the sub welcome
welcome welcome
this part right here this first part
the scale
i don't know about you guys but that
showcase absolutely blew me away
it blew me away like
i had in my mind what i thought hogwarts
legacy was gonna be
and then when we saw that like here's
what i was picturing and then they just
like took it so much bigger than i was
expecting so i almost immediately
thought ah
and then they announced holiday 2022 so
it's like oh
it's like the double they're not they're
not committing to even a month yet
they're just committing to holiday so i
almost immediately back when we had the
showcase i'm like oh
this is so crazy ambitious
they're they're trying to do
so much of what fans have want have
wanted
i could see it getting delayed again
then the i mean we had the showcase
everything looked great there
but it was just so ambitious
so i i agree with him on that part it
would not be unusual for a game this big
to move even further back that's the
thing we got to remember this is the
biggest game avalanche has ever made
um they've never made a game quite like
this it's also the most amount of time
they have had to work on a single game
all right so moving on these other
points uh i don't
well we'll just go through here it
remains one of the only big games in the
holiday schedule that does not have a
release date true factual it has been
listed as december 22 for a while now i
think he's
slightly misinformed on that one it's
been holiday 2022 but
most of us have guessed december but
when games uh when games even with fixed
dates are being delayed it's unclear why
it wouldn't have picked one by now
and this is the big thing like this is
why people keep
asking questions what like what's going
on here you know it's august i've said
i'll give it through this month before
i'm really like okay it's getting
delayed but if september 1st comes and
goes because i think everybody's kind of
like
pinpointing september 1st back to
hogwarts day that's a great opportunity
for them to just do a big huge
announcement there's also the rumors of
another playstation state of play uh or
maybe not maybe not even stay to play
maybe like a big their big showcase
event for the year uh and clearly
hogwarts has some sort of um marketing
deal with them
this point i don't think i agree i don't
agree with him as much on this one
frankly we have not seen all that much
of the game i mean come on they showed
over
14 minutes of game of gameplay footage
in the sony state of play admittedly
that was back in march but we were
approaching six months after that and
have not gotten anything of real
significance from the game beside what
was shown there oh i beg to differ sir
i beg to differ check out the youtube
channel youtube.com retrorecontour we've
learned a great deal since then
and they've been kind of doing you know
those little updates that they post on
social media but the autodesk one which
we're gonna get to here in a second that
was the big one kind of unusual for a
game that should be starting to ramp up
product promotion excuse me for a
holiday release
that part i think is somewhat right on
you know i i would have expected more of
a ramp up by now
and when i say more of a ramp up you
want to start to see things like like
web like what the heck this federalist
papers thing no no idea why i'm getting
served this advertisement um but so
things like this you know you want to
start seeing this on ign on gamestop for
hogwarts legacy uh they would run those
for you know a couple months you would
expect to see things like uh
you gotta think they're gonna do a tv ad
for this they're probably gonna do ads
online on youtube that sort of thing
so that's the type of thing that i'm
talking about we is like the hardcore
who are watching every move their
twitter account makes
we've been picking up on all these
little things that they're releasing
along the way shadow fiend hey welcome
thank you so much for the sub there
so this one you know i'd say he's he's
partially right but
not seen all that much
you know 50 50 there back in early 2022
there were rumors that hogwarts legacy
was quote in trouble and an industry
insider said that it was on track to be
pushed back to 2023. this was before the
december 2022 window was given so
perhaps that was not the case but it's
still something that was floating around
out there about development so what he's
referencing here is colin moriarty
of uh formerly of ign then he was at
kind of funny then now he does um oh
geez
last stand media i i can't remember what
the name of his um sacred symbols is the
name of the playstation podcast
but he he had mentioned almost in kind
of an offhand way that he had heard this
was again as paul tasty says here this
was way back before we even saw the
state of play
so then we got the state of play and
everybody's like oh wow you know this
looks amazing they're good
but that was floating around out there
all right then this is the end here
these last two paragraphs to sum up this
seems like a hugely ambitious project
agree with you there paul big time agree
with you there one that is one of the
only remaining big releases this year
without a firm date yep that's just
factual and one that has not shown us
much footage or given us many details in
a very very long time
if i was a betting man i'd say this one
is on the cusp and in the era of post
cyberpunk 2077 no one wants to release
before they're ready
we gotta talk about this too because
i guarantee you any hogwarts legacy
video i post if you scroll through the
comments cyberpunk will be mentioned
somewhere
which i i get sick of it but it's
something i feel like is just
unavoidable naturally now that i've
written this i love how he adds this
though naturally and now that i've
written this i expect some giant new
trailer and announced released it within
a few hours stay tuned for that i
suppose
the end so if you guys are just tuning
in jumping in wondering what the heck we
are reading from here this is uh an
article posted by forbes today
uh their senior contributor paul tasi he
does a lot of video game stuff a lack of
a hogwarts legacy release date this late
raises questions now he's not the only
one who's been saying this uh there are
other people who have been saying this
as well so i'm gonna get caught up with
the comments here see if you guys have
had any questions
relating to this
favorite character in the harry potter
movies that's tough i mean
i was always a huge dobby fan to be
honest i love dobby
um as i was reading the books though i'd
probably have to say dumbledore
i feel like uh antonio says feel like
almost every game is hiding game player
info this year for example nba 2k23 the
game is launching in a month almost
nothing was shown
see that's the thing like as much as i
hate talking about cyberpunk and i hate
that everybody brings it up
i do feel like it's we're starting to
see that it's clearly impacted the
industry
in some very interesting ways
and
i mean i think people are kind of
terrified now to release
in a broken state when when before maybe
before cyberpunk people would be like ah
you know what that one
that bug let's just get it out the door
we can patch that in a couple weeks
cyberpunk change thing now to be fair
cyberpunk was not just one or two bugs
right i mean there was a lot there
uh but i mean there have been lawsuits
between companies cd projekt red and
other companies over cyberpunk so i
think it i think it's pretty clearly had
an impact on the industry now
i don't know that we can say that's
exactly what's going on here i have no
idea
i have no idea but i think it's it's
definitely impacted things
uh ryu or ryu i don't think it's getting
delayed i think they're just hiding the
release date to build a pipe
amir hogwarts legacy coming up this year
don't worry
uh cursed barkley yo it's been delayed
one i think
means delayed once people need to chill
see i will say this too i think 2021 was
a big mistake
i i don't know if that was avalanches
doing i don't know if that was wb
i don't know if that was portkey i don't
know if it was sony
i don't know if it was
the powers that be
but clearly the game was nowhere close
to being ready for 2021
my my guess is that
they have a they have a marketing deal
with playstation we're pretty clear on
that
playstation gave them prime
position i mean prime real estate
on the floor i mean floor in air quotes
here of the playstation 5 showcase event
i mean when they were fully unveiling
the ps5 hogwarts legacy was one of the
trailers shown think about how big of a
deal that is for them to show them on
that type of stage
so i don't i don't think they forced
them to say 2021 but i think there could
have been some pressure maybe from sony
if like
man
we really want to you know build a pipe
for the console we really want to
showcase all the games that are coming
to it even though hogwarts legacy is
multi-platform before anyone hears this
and starts getting worried it is
multi-platform but i could see them
being like do you think like is there a
chance like 20 21 is that is that what
we want to go with okay yeah okay 20 21.
i have no idea that's just me
speculating santa panda a welcome thank
you so much for the sub
but i could see that people you know
maybe jump the gun there because
the fact that you hit
timey or timmy maybe kroll hey thank you
for the sub
the fact that they immediately hit 2021
and very early they're like oh yeah this
ain't happening it's delayed we'll talk
more next year the whole year so we had
to go that whole year
oh man
so yeah i think that's that's a big part
of it all right let's see catching up on
the comments here
lack of information is uh
yeah it's kind of frustrating but
i'll say i think chandler's doing a
great job with what he's been given
the community manager he's very limited
in what and what he can say
um but i think this kind of
these these regular updates are better
than nothing i mean these weekly posts
that they they're on a pretty good
cadence they've had a pretty good streak
going of a post each week if they start
to go totally dark that's when
everybody's gonna be like
what is happening
what is happening when's gamescom uh we
looked at that last time it's here in a
couple weeks
pretty sure
trying to play this game before i die
tomorrow isn't promised i mean that
you're right about that man we never
know how much longer we have vandal
hope hope nothing serious is going on
there vandal
hope you're uh
[Music]
hope you're not facing something
too too too harsh there man it makes me
think about that this this uh this
reddit post there's a
a guy who posts on the harry potter
subreddit about how he actually posted
this many months ago he was afraid he
wasn't going to be able to
live for the release
um and the hogwarts legacy folks sent
him like a signed poster by a lot of the
devs really nice gesture but this person
just posted recently and it sounds like
they're doing a lot better so
that's good news
hopefully this pushes the producers to
give out a date soon santa says yeah
like i just
at this point
oh man
i just i like at this point i feel like
i'm i'm gonna stick to august like like
if we go through august
september 1st and we get nothing on a
date
they they they have to say something
soon about the date
coming this close to the holidays and it
gets delayed don't you think they should
tell us now i i agree with that like
rick i think if they if they already
know now
if they know internally that's getting
delayed i mean just like rip the
band-aid off right come on
rip the band-aid off i could totally see
them though trying to get something
ready
to package with it
so it's not just like oh we're delayed
maybe it's like we're delayed but here's
a new trailer show you what we've been
working on or it's delayed but here's
the collector edition that we're so
excited
that kind of thing
like the breadcrumbs they give us yeah
barkley ah okay that makes so much more
sense
where it was where bark was capitalized
and then lee i'm like curse barkley
but curse barkley i like that
reputation system would be cool similar
to uh honoring red dead two
treaty different based on what you're
known for that that would be super cool
i agree
that's one thing that they haven't i
mean they showed us quite a bit of
footage and the whole sort of
we don't even know if there really is a
morality system all we know is that in
the faq they said you're gonna have to
make choices that are gonna impact
impact the game basically that's all i
really know
hi iq warrior what's up welcome back do
you think hogwarts legacy comes out
december 6th
my
my guess
if it hits this year i've said december
6th
the more that
time has passed
like if expecto go asked me to do
another video
um i would predict a delay now i would i
would think i would guess like february
mid-february is what i would guess now
but yeah december 6th honestly i mean
just feels like the perfect day i hope
it releases december 6 because that i
feel like that is the perfect
i mean you guys just look at the games
that are like moving out of 2022
it's like you got god of war you got
pokemon you got call of duty they're
gonna sell crazy no matter what i mean
it's just such a unique opportunity in
early december for hogwarts it's gonna
sell well regardless no matter what sure
it definitely is
oh i like this question from uh manav
any chance of getting chandler for an
interview so
chandler probably
i would guess he can't give out many
interviews right now i mean maybe if
like you know an ign
or a game stop
came calling wait game spot
ign a game spot you know one of the big
video game sites came calling maybe he
would be able to give an interview um
but i'll i have reached out to chandler
and chandler and i have uh messages each
other in in twitter dms and we've
interacted on twitter publicly as well i
would love to have chandler on
i think probably closer to the game like
once chandler's able to talk a little
bit more i mean because right now if
chandler came on it would
it would probably be a show of uh
more soon stay tuned more soon stay
tuned
one thing they may be able to answer now
like i would love to know
some of the details of like the switch
version like what like where did that
come from at what point did they decide
to add the switch version
ellie didn't get a notification for this
glad you catch it hey glad you stopped
by as well ellie welcome back pretty
sure you were here last week
yeah i don't really i i will say ellie i
did not get the uh
last week i was able to post the i love
this is one thing i love about live
streams on youtube is i can schedule a
stream
and so then if you guys have watched a
lot of videos on the channel you'll see
the thumbnail appear
kind of in your home page and say it'll
like give you like a little countdown
but i didn't get to post it today until
like about half an hour or so before
before i was able to hop on but yeah i'm
gonna in the future i'm gonna try and
start posting that earlier in the day
and i feel like tuesday is gonna be a
good day for this we'll see if i can
stick to it
my oldest son is getting ready to start
school back up tomorrow so he's in third
grade this year so once school starts
it kind of takes a little bit to get
back into that routine
um but yeah we're shooting for each
tuesday
sad because reminding my friends oh i'm
sorry to hear that mary
i just had a i just had a co-worker at
at work who
lost their father completely
unexpectedly as well
very sorry to hear that
uh
okay
yeah wtf hey welcome thank you for the
sub
game looks like it'd have a lot of
potential bugs joshua says
i mean they've showed some on twitter
and i i kind of applaud them for doing
that for poking fun dakota a dakota
thank you for the sub as well
i'm just going to call you avatar maori
mayori avatar maybe thank you for the
sub
uh gryffindor metal
i'm gryffindor
but speaking of bugs though
so
for those of you who've been following
the channel for a bit you know that i i
posted an article not an article a video
talking about that i've talked to two
people behind the scenes
who told me that quidditch who would
know people very familiar with the game
who said that quidditch is not going to
be playable
one of them also told me they would be
very surprised if the game hit 2022.
now i didn't make a video on that
because it was just from one person and
it wasn't you know it didn't sound
concrete
but from their perspective it did not
they did not feel it was likely
that the game would make it in 2022
so that's why i haven't
talked about it more but
now with all these kind of rumors and
stuff popping up i think i think i see
where they uh could be coming from
oh let's see glad i made it wasn't sure
hey white wolf welcome
yeah guys so we just uh we just walked
through yo did i see the boy james
expecto go
pop it in before my podcast to say yo
and smash the like button
hey james thanks so much guys i'm
working to get uh working to get i was
about to say working to get games
working to get james
on the show
at least once as well
james and i have interacted on twitter
many times we've talked in dms i watch
every video he posts
but i i really want to get like have a
live have a uh
a legitimate conversation with james
because
i was joking last time james i don't
know if you got to see if you were
watching last week
i said i'm kind of afraid at the same
time because if you get james and i
together i feel like
we're the kind of fans who could just
like start talking and then five hours
goes by and we're just like oh where
where did time go
because
man between your your theories and i
could just see how how long you've been
a fan of the series
we would have a lot to discuss i know
that
i want to what i really want to ask you
james well there's a lot of questions
but i i really want to talk to you about
the origins of the merlin theory
and then i want to i feel like we need
to bring some clarity to the merlin
theory james we we need to we've talked
so much about her you've talked so much
about it on all your videos i think i
think we need to boil it down let's get
into like one clear theory
of how much merlin is going to play a
role in hogwarts legacy
because i i james has persuaded me you
guys i think it's going to be a big one
i think merlin's going to have a huge
role in hogwarts legacy
amazing cjb you sub hey thanks so much
cj
hi iq if they delayed to next year i
hope they had quidditch
if they delay
it's not going to be to add anything
sorry to disappoint you high iq if they
delay it is at this point it is purely
to get the game across the finish line
to polish up to bug fix i think that's
the stage they're in now i really do i
feel like they are in the home stretch
and i feel like they are just trying to
get the game
i don't think anything's majorly wrong i
don't think it's like some
super
big problems with the game i just think
it's like they want it to be as clean as
possible
hey everyone merlin's wand that's why we
get on hogwarts radar late a fig comes
oh and fig maybe comes to find us hey
that's possible
will playstation be getting more content
justice asked i don't believe so
i gotta think there's
some perk for sony and this marketing
deal
uh we don't know anything about that at
this point though i
i wouldn't expect so maybe if they do
dlc like playstation get some early
access to that
but yeah we'll see you're a wizard harry
rex high tech you're a wizard welcome
welcome imagine it gets delayed another
year tristan said nah i definitely don't
think that i think it's kind of just to
get it over the finish line samuel as
well samuel thank you so much for the
sub
i think the ravenclaw companion is more
important than we think you're a wizard
ellie says the merlin theories
yeah the merlin theory
so good spade a welcome spade the thing
about merlin is like we've already got
confirmation
like that he's a major part of the game
right i mean through the puzzles and we
see his name on the stained glass
but how much will he play into the story
that's the big one merlin comes as a
force ghost
dude what if merlin was a ghost and he
just like hasn't talked to anybody for
all these years
uh about the ravenclaw question though i
go back and forth on that like i can't
figure out why
i'm trying to figure out why would they
have kept it hidden is it just a matter
of
they want to have at least one more
companion that we can kind of speculate
and wonder about or
is it someone that's going to have a big
like maybe it's someone with a last name
that we know you think about the other
three that they unveiled they were names
that we you know have no connection to
the uh
original series as far as we know
i think morgana is going to be one that
we talk about from now on
yeah morgana expect to go ahead a good
video up on that as well
high iq warrior by delay i mean not just
a few months but another one year delay
oh yeah
i don't think they would do that
definitely not
hope that our character is the
descendant and heir of merlin himself
summoned by the ancient magic j rossi
what's up dude welcome
which could be a dlc yeah i could see
that i could see that charles
flashbacks to harry saying flipping
ever since they said things about
secrets and rural in the trailer yeah it
was almost like they wanted us to go in
that direction right mary
it's like they're nudging us there
like come on
look into merlin look into merlin
could it be impacted by the recent
warner brothers discovery merger
joshua that
that's a big question
uh priestess a thanks for the sub that
is a big question i made a video way
back when that merger first happened and
i think i must have went too technical
because the video didn't didn't do that
well noah welcome thank you for the sub
as well
uh
that one's hard to answer because
initially i would have said no because
we thought the game i mean if the game
is coming out this year no i don't think
it's gonna have any impact unless unless
you talk like
multiple dlcs down the line or a sequel
i do think it could have an impact for
that
um
but as we saw like apparently this new
president ceo just just canceled batgirl
which was pretty much done but
apparently was in such bad shape that
they didn't want to release it
so
i don't see anything like that happening
i think worst case scenario like worst
case
like let's say because so far wb has
been very patient with avalanche there
they seem to be on the same page giving
them all the time they need
but let's say that this new this new guy
is like
what the heck is going on here they've
been working on this for how long
no i'm giving them they have one more
month to finish
then they have one month to
polish to do updates and bugs and then
we're done and then we get like no pulse
post launch support
so that to me that would be the worst
case scenario i don't think we'd ever
see like them just cancel the game
that'd be crazy at this point but if
that ceo is like and the people behind
the scenes doing the finances the bean
counters the money counters all that
because you know they're they're kind of
weighing here okay they're working on
this game they've been working on how
long
if it's coming out this year or january
february i don't think we have any any
issues if if they have to delay it any
longer than that
then i think you could see somebody like
that new ceo step in and be like okay
what's going on here
and trying to uh
alter things there
let's see
turn 16 in four weeks nice nice
since a mega potterhead oh dude we got
all the mega potterheads in here
collecting bertie bought beans wait what
did tristan say about birdie bop bean oh
yeah
the flashback to flopindo yeah that's
one of the biggest things people
remember about the game the fupindo and
the birdy bop beans
if merlin was the defense against the
dark arch
defense against the dark arts teacher
that'd be insanity
check all the banners mid-fights in the
trailer uh i have yeah yeah i've went
through them i don't know if i made a
video about every single one but i have
i have went through and talked about
some of them
oh ravenclaw companion is sebast
sebastian sallow's sister that'd be
interesting
professor fake for ravenclaw merlin is
the main antagonist 100
yo
microsoft buys avalanche to troll sony
oh my gosh
never been interested in harry potter
following talk about this game so
closely it looks so good
can totally see myself coming potterhead
just for this game hey you should i mean
check out the books
check out the books so good so good
fig is the big bad a i feel like that's
a big popular theory that's been coming
out
recently
all right let's let's talk about this uh
let's talk about this autodesk
session
and the first thing i want to talk about
is this right here
this right here
professors
somebody said fig it made me think about
it somebody was talking about merlin as
the defense against the dark arch
teacher that made me think about it so
uh let's see who is this on reddit
i have no sci-fi nerd 10 put this
together slytherin house shout out to
slytherin and sci-fi nerd for putting
this together here
so if you guys haven't seen yet
uh will's world yo thank you for the sub
will
most of you have probably watched it if
you haven't there was an autodesk
presentation where hogwarts legacy was
was a participant i'd never heard of
autodesk before this
i had never heard of it
and it was an industry thing so there
was a lot of very technical stuff here
but they also showed us a lot of things
that the game we hadn't seen before we
saw a lot of
the game in progress of being developed
so we saw all kinds of file names
and you know what we harry potter
investigators love to do
when we get any little morsel of
information we're going to drill down
we're going to find all the little
nuggets so i think there were some
things that they clearly were okay with
us seeing and then maybe one or two that
they weren't sure if we were going to
find but uh we found them we have found
them and i still like i said i may go
back and do another video on that
because there was so much
so much stuff that they included here
and one of the things out of it is we
think we have now learned the identity
one professor for sure 100 confirmed by
chandler wood on twitter
and that is this professor right here
abraham ronan it's actually spelled with
an e r-o-n-e-n
and he is confirmed to be a slytherin so
a lot of us when we saw that trailer we
caught the snakes
right here
and right here
confirmed as your charms professor in
hogwarts legacy right here abraham ronan
so that one 100 confirmed
uh and so we knew this person was the
charms professor the things that
chandler confirmed that we didn't
necessarily know before is we learned
his uh name
and then we also got confirmation on his
house all right now how did this first
start
i have so many screenshots saved from
this autodesk session let me pull this
one up for you guys right here
so this i want to be clear about what
this is for any of you who didn't get to
see the presentation this is a look at
the internal tool so this is avalanche
building this this is not what we're
going to see on our end we did get a
glimpse at that too though
of what it's going to look like on our
end when we're creating our character so
just because you see um
like let's see like we see ring and we
see socks like just because we see socks
that is not a guarantee that we're going
to be able to customize our socks
in the game maybe i mean who knows right
maybe but it's not a guarantee these are
just things that they're able to adjust
like you see things like the height here
so we know that he's 6-1
uh professor abraham ronan we get that
right here and then all of these are
things i guess that they can like tweak
and customize about the character
so this is where we first saw this
somebody screen capped this and then
chandler shared it and said yep you guys
spotted it correct here's the slytherin
emblem
this is 100 confirmed
gives off the raven ravenclaw vibe a bit
well i think it's good that we get a
slytherin who is so
starkly different from obviously snape
i mean you could just tell by his
personality right
very different from snape but also
even very different from slughorn and so
i can't wait for us to get to know him
even more
in the game
customizable socks right clue if we
don't get crushed customizable socks we
riot
come on now i want i want those uh
gold and red socks for gryffindor
dude that'd be all i mean
clearly they're programmed into the game
the question is will we be able to
change them probably not but you never
know
you never know
socks already confirmed
dude can we get what if we like
accidentally give a sock to the house
elf they just like walk out of hogwarts
[Music]
oh man
all right so
not really much else to see in this one
and there's where you can see the full
spelling right there aron eaton
uh i do love this up here though i wish
they would have showed off some of the
different emotions like how many
different emotions do they have
programmed in there for the facial
animations and that sort of thing so
chandler then confirmed that we know
that 100 percent ellie is our fig we
know he's professor
the subject is unknown we are
speculating between transfiguration or
ancient runes uh ancient runes probably
makes the most sense because
of we see him kind of taking our main
character around exploring these
different uh dungeons these different
secret areas that sort of thing
but it could be transfiguration as well
we're trying to do like process of
elimination here to figure all this out
cuthbert bins of course everybody knows
professor bins this one was
not ex uh it was not unexpected so this
was not a shock at all professor bin's
for history of magic
and let's see
oh why did i
why did i lose oh here we go i gotta go
over to the next one now
phineas
black i always mispronounce that so i'm
just skipping over it
i don't know that we can say this
for certainty on this one
and it's probably best if we kind of
work backwards from this and start with
professor sharp over here
uh a lot of people
james from podcast now myself included i
actually thought this right here was
phineas black
mainly because he looks so much like
sirius or gary oldman from the movies
he looks so much like him
um but he also just kind of like you can
tell he kind of has this surly
disposition he's just he comes in he
like slams the potion on the table
and we all know that phineas did not
enjoy teaching students
so i was all in on that being him
well there was a section oh i need to
see if i have a i don't know if i have a
screenshot of this one or not i don't
think i do but there was a section in
that autodesk presentation
that showed
the name of uh it said potions professor
sharp now something i want you to pay
attention to here this is sharp is five
letters one two three four five no just
remember that
professor sharp
i'm i'm not 100 convinced just based on
that i'll say that i'm not 100 convinced
on that
however i do think this is the most
likely scenario here i think this is
phineas black
and i think this is professor sharp
with the possibility
that his last name is actually something
longer
because that is where we also see on the
same screen where we see this the
professor sharp potions we also see
professor hecaty which that most people
are telling me to pronounce this hecate
after the greek goddess hecate which is
h-e-c-a-t-e
but it doesn't have the e so maybe
they're going with a slightly different
pronunciation here heckats hecat
maybe
or
maybe there's something going on with
their file name see this is how detailed
we're going in on this right
maybe there's something with their file
names
that in that particular shot we see cuts
it off at five
or maybe that's just like their
structures they use the first five of
their last name and that's why i said
pay attention to the fact that sharp is
five letters
this is also five letters and this one
like i just it'd be kind of weird if
they just dropped the e unless they just
wanted to you know differentiate it a
bit
um so hecate
hecate maybe if they uh
if they aren't going with the greek
goddess pronunciation
she is almost positively defense against
the dark arts because she is the one
that we see in the scene where they are
dueling and we see her in the defense
against the dark arts classroom
i think she looks like the raven a
ravenclaw to me
maybe it's just the blue you know and
again then again he's wearing green and
uh maybe slytherin maybe not we don't
know but um
professor ronan is wearing purple and
he's slytherin so we can't just go by
the colors
so then phineas black if this um
is not phineas then i think that's right
i think this right here is phineas and i
think he's most likely the headmaster
which could be really fun it could be
really fun that he's the headmaster
all right
that's not all though
we got more
so let's just double back here so
confirmed right here 100 confirmed 100
confirmed uh fig is obviously definitely
a confirmed professor we know his full
name
uh but we just don't know the subject
i'll i'll say most likely ancient runes
all right page three here
professor weasley
this lady right here so this is the lady
that we see
putting the sorting hat on our character
and also she is the one who introduces
us into the room of requirement
you can see her in that shot where
kimmy hey thank you for the sub kimmy
welcome
you can see her in that scene where
actually the text for room of
requirement pops up on screen and it
kind of spins around the camera spins
around you can see her there
why are people saying she's a weasley
because a lot of other people are saying
no the weasley's got to be the redhead
right the weasley has to be the
redheaded
herbology teacher here's why
there was a shot in this autodesk
presentation and i know i have this one
screenshot here it's kind of it's a
weird screenshot be warned
this is when they talked about the the
motion capture stuff that they had to do
for this game which was crazy because
they were having to film so much of it
during covid
and uh
so they had to like make it seem like
the way they filmed like you could see
like she's recording this in her house i
believe
and then above it's kind of hard to see
but that that says weasley right there
weasley
then this person right here is the
player character there are some more
shots they showed on this i'm just
pulling out this one screenshot here
then right here we see
her
and look at the scarf look at the hair
which looks very much like
this lady here
and honestly that's enough for me i'm
i'm not saying confirmed because
i mean you could change things like
names you could change that this late in
the game
but given this right here that we see
this is we says weasley here
and given that we see her here matching
this up
i think this is almost
certainly professor weasley i think this
is correct
weasley's probably yeah she could very
well be the gryffindor the gryffindor um
oh my gosh what's the term i just lost
it
they've got the house ghost head of like
head of house
mcgonagall's head of gryffindor house
this one i have no idea where they've
got this name
do you guys know chat let me know
ernesto jag
i i don't know where that one came from
i've not seen that specific name
mentioned anywhere
so if you guys know where that came from
let me know while you guys are thinking
about that i'm going to speculate about
her subject i saw some people throwing
out muggle studies
i think it could be transfiguration
i think it would make a lot of sense if
she's transfiguration
and
then we have um
fig for ancient runes
so fig ancient runes
and then weasley for transfiguration
100 that's professor weasley
i agree very convincing hard are you not
being right yeah i i'm
unless they like totally change
something which to be fair let me pull
that screenshot up that i
that i had moments ago
to be fair it does say right up here
layout version 618 2021.
now something like a professor name you
would think that would be pretty set in
stone given that they've got to write
the story and all that around it
obviously they're not going to redo a
bunch of um
voice over unless they absolutely had to
so yeah i think you could just about
take that one to the bank
charles doesn't think fig will be a
teacher that could be possible as well
i could see that
i could see that
all right so
uh this lady right here the librarian i
don't think we have any indication of a
name at all on that one
and then i'm not sure why they're
associating him with care of magical
creatures
so that one i'm also not sure about that
one could just be some speculation there
as well
which i guess i mean i guess she could
be care of magical creatures too
honestly professor weasley could
all right and then the last page here
uh this teacher 100 confirmed for
herbology
a lot of folks are speculating that this
is the long rumored helen thistlewood
which to me makes so much sense
so way back when gosh this has been
probably a year or more ago
there was uh some imdb updates which
again imdb that is certainly not
official at all
so we can't you know take that as 100
but this one i mean this one seemed
legit there were a couple of actors and
voice over people that got posted
uh and helen thistlewood was the name of
one of those
which
i mean think about it you had professor
sprout who taught herbology
now a helen thistlewood teaching
herbology
i think would make a lot of sense
this professor almost certainly the
flying instructor i think we also see
this professor in the uh
first scene the sorting scene i think we
see her sitting back
behind the uh
like behind where they have the sorting
ceremony set up
and then this professor right here
astronomy or divination
astronomy or
divination which i agree with that too
i don't think they'll have astronomy in
the game so i think it's probably
divination
i think this is the divination professor
here
one someone in a comment today i wish i
could remember their name on one of the
youtube videos commented today saying
that
um
it'd be interesting if they had
astronomy because it would be a night
class
it would be a night class and
as far as we know i'm pretty sure that's
the only night class at hogwarts
and we were talking last week we were
talking about the
how the timing is going to work and if
you have to take all your classes in the
day well if they had astronomy that
could be one potential night class as
well that we would have
so that is the wrap-up of the
what we have learned based on this
autodesk presentation and i did see
somebody uh high iq warrior in the 1890s
this is from the wiki
ah
okay
gotcha hike you warrior that makes a lot
of sense so from the wiki in the 1890s
he had a small animal pin on the grounds
of hogwarts just beside the black lake
with a small equipment store marked
professor ernesto jaggs veterinary
supplies
that would be interesting and i bet
that's where they're getting it
professor ernesto jag
oh i like that
i don't know that that's a name and i've
ever come across
in all of my reading of the harry potter
wiki and all that i don't remember ever
seeing that name
so yeah that one i don't think we can
say confirmed but i i think that could
uh let's just say plausible plausible on
that one
and then on the last page here uh
somebody said thought that was a student
not a professor this one right here well
i think we see this same
professor in the background
of the uh
right here
yeah i think that's definitely the same
one right there so this screenshot here
so you can see that we we're almost
positive this is professor weasley the
divination professor where i've stopped
it right here you can't see her there's
a
ronin right there
and then we have this professor right
here which we don't know the name yet
but yeah and then some people also said
maybe that uh professor weasley here is
also the deputy headmistress just like
mcgonagall so if you remember mcgonagall
was the one who comes in and puts the
sorting hat on harry
so what do you guys think
let me know in the comments below
about the potential professors i like it
i think it makes a lot of sense on all
of these
for me let's see the biggest one
obviously we still don't know her name
that's kind of a big thing we still
don't know we don't know if this is
astronomy or divination
the uh i feel pretty good about the
flying one here
um i feel i feel pretty confident about
this being professor weasley subject
we just really don't have any idea right
now on that one ernesto jag
5050 maybe i would say
i don't know maybe more that maybe 60 40
because of uh if that wiki entry is is
correct there
uh almost positive this is the librarian
we just don't know her name
professor sharp that one i would i'm
much less certain of that one
clearly this is the potions professor
though for sure
and then we have hecate
defense against the dark arts
yeah i feel pretty good
i feel i feel solid about those unless
it's like unless the name is uh we
talked about that five letter thing
maybe their file management
cuts it off or they they limit it to
five characters after for the name
so that would be most likely phineas
black
then we have ronin then we have fig then
we have bins
cw have a good night thanks for stopping
by
yeah you're right uh rossi the recent
tweet showed uh
the bottom of the divination tower it
showed the ladder dropping down
herb oh man
her biology professor is the main
villain that's that would be good
because that
if you look at that lineup the herbology
professor is probably the least likely
other i mean if if it's professor
weasley come on professor weasley's got
to be
on the good side right
jj ay thank you so much for the sub jj
welcome welcome
why wouldn't they just use a magical
enchanted sky to do the daytime hey i
mean that's they probably could right
they probably could
i feel like it's gonna be a short game
i don't know
i don't think so i don't think so the
the showcase i think showed a ton
that lead me to believe it it should be
a very
what's the word like densely packed
experience the fact that they're not
even just limiting it just to hogwarts
we're going outside of hogwarts too
that's when i was really like oh wow
okay they're going that deep with this
all right
all right
weasley student i think so maximilian
yeah i think i think that the professor
weasley
is uh maybe the parent or grandparent of
one of the students
at hogwarts
they even said uh in one of the blog
posts they said a weasley or two so i
think we get the professor and then
maybe one or possibly two more
defense gets the dark arts possibly the
weasley instead i don't think so because
the the file name that we saw
that's where we got the hecate the
h-e-c-a-t
and the um
i just think if you go and line up
the shots from whoops
wrong thing
if you go and look at the shots from
this right here
i mean like that that is like almost
dead on
this one right here
and of course that was early too you
know before they even have
but even then you know you already you
got you got like the buttons right there
you got the scarf
grave rob more than 40 more or less than
40 hours
i think definitely more to see and do
everything
i feel like if you're just if you're
just focusing on the story
maybe 30 to 35
and i mean this this is purely me
guessing by the way like
purely me guessing
if a weasley was working with the
goblins
main story probably be short be able to
get lost in the world for hours and
hours doing other activities
yo ella hey thank you so much for
stopping by and letting me know it's my
pleasure i
i love making hogwarts legacy content
and giving you guys a chance to uh i
mean really any video game content but
we've kind of hit our groove with
hogwarts legacy
but i mean there was just somebody in
here earlier people talking about losing
loved ones and
i don't know like it just it really puts
things into perspective of like
it sounds crazy because some people
think games are just a waste of time but
i'm like do you realize how much games
like help people to relax and help
people to
sort of unwind and sort of deal with
real world troubles and real world pain
so not to get too sappy on you guys but
i mean really like i
to hear comments like that i i really do
appreciate it so thank you glad you got
to stop by and check out a live stream
as well
uh nicole's uh what stage of development
the game is uh it's nearing the end for
sure even uh there's rumors of a delay
it's definitely nearing the end they're
certainly in the polishing they're in
the bug fixing stage
all they've said all that we have
confirmed is that they were targeting a
2022
holiday release date is the last
official word we had
so i think it's safe to say that you
know they're they're nearing the finish
line for sure
multiple endings white wolf i think so
because
otherwise why even give choices right
why even give choices you at least gotta
have two endings preferably three if
you're gonna give people choices
what if the herbology teacher yeah a lot
of people have thought i mean just
putting the two and two together with
the red hair i don't think so though i
don't think the herbology teacher is uh
mcgonagall i don't think the herbology
is a weasley but could be i mean we'll
see right
we will see
let's see personally believe that the
ravenclaw companion could possibly be
the second weasley they were talking
about not sure if always is our
gryffindor
i think
let me show you this other screenshot i
gotta go into a different file for this
one but
i think we see
the other weasley i think they're a
gryffindor
which i don't think they have to be
gryffindor i mean yeah most of the
weasleys are in gryffindor but i don't
think it's like a lock that they
oh by the way here's the other shot i
forgot to show this one it's kind of
hard to see but that's the other shot
where we see the uh
what most people are thinking is
professor weasley
right there that room of requirement
scene
okay let me go into my hogwarts so i can
see folder
look through all the screenshots that i
have here
okay photos hogwarts legacy
i think it was even an official
screenshot
not even one that we just pulled from
where is it where is it where is it i've
got so many screenshots of this game
saved of the trailers
okay
this shot right here is one of them
this person right here
i think that person is a weasley
and i think
yeah that looks like gryffindor to me
and then there's another spot where we
see almost i'm pretty sure this exact
same character somewhere else
in one of the other trailers
or in the the other trailer
dark lord weasley from slytherin house
stephen thinks he'll have more content
than we expect
need this game already so it became the
second job second full-time job
yeah i hope it's a world we could just
get lost in for sure
physical deluxe oh jay i hope so
i'm really hoping so on that and some of
the leaks
on the
on the uh collector's editions and stuff
man i really hope so
i really hope so
uh fig i don't think fig is the
headmaster because that would go against
what we know
let's see would it go against what we
know about the cannon
hey the old jackaroo thank you so much
for the two dollar super chat will
classmates be the same or different each
play through oh wow
i think i think the same
i think they'll be the same
now what would be really cool is if like
i never thought about that though like
if aside from the companions
what if they were like random it's like
you'd see different classmate like
you're like oh i remember seeing that
person in a previous playthrough but
they were in that house
that would be pretty cool i feel like
the companions like any characters that
play a role in the story i feel like
they would definitely have to be
set where they're at you know like like
natsai or natty as we have learned her
nickname i can't imagine that uh
she'd be in like a different house or
something
but yeah thank you so much for
supporting the channel and thank you for
the question
all right so let's talk about a couple
of other i want to show you guys all the
screenshots that i saved
from this autodesk thing
i had it in the thumbnail so we gotta
talk about it
we gotta talk about this one right here
because we got one of our best looks yet
at the character creator for hogwarts
legacy
now i want to show you guys another very
old screenshot as well
telling you guys like
the files of everything i have saved
regarding hogwarts legacy this right
here anybody remember this one
only the people who have been following
the game for a long long time remember
this one
because this one was from a leak
this one was from a leak very very long
ago
so you can see they had face types they
had skin color they had eye color just
some of your basics i actually really
like the visuals of the menu here
i kind of i kind of like this this
layout of it
but if you go to the new one
i mean as we're as we're gonna see when
we go through here just way way way more
options
now there's a a lot of things about this
shot right here that i don't think i've
seen many people talking about yet
um
this right here
i think this confirms
that the scene we see of fig
and our character
going to what appears to be gringotts
i think is all pre hogwarts before we
get to hogwarts
and i think this i think this just about
confirms that we're going to start the
game
meeting up with fig to head to gringotts
maybe we do diagon alley i don't expect
diagon alley
because they've shown so much
yo hi123 with the super chat no question
just the support dude thank you so much
really appreciate the super chats you
guys very much appreciated
um
so yeah like this right here
i think this attire just about confirms
it just about confirms that that's where
we start
um so this is one shot that we see and
this this page right here is the presets
i did think it was interesting that
everything we've seen so far is on
playstation and this one clearly was on
xbox or at least they were very
they were using the xbox controller
because it says rb there instead of r1
and then lb over there
all right so it wasn't just this tab
though that we got to look at
if you went very very slow you could
actually screen cap every one of these
tabs
here's the next tab right here faceware
which i
faceware like is that is that a british
term or something that i'm not familiar
with because
faceware seems like things you would
wear on your face when it just appears
like
that you're controlling your face shape
right here
you're doing skin color right here and
then it does glasses i mean so i guess
glasses would be face wear
so you see that they've got three
options for glasses
judging from this right here let's see 3
6 9 12 15.
15 options for the face which there
could be more i don't think we can say
that this is this is it right here
because we can't like see
if it can scroll more left or right or
if there's more up and down here and
then we don't know maybe there's stuff
that fall after glasses here
here's the next one hairstyles so this
is the next tab over
yeah exactly mary like why not
why not just face
face wear that that being the heading or
even like face shape at the top
but face wear up there that's kind of
strange to me and again who knows how
long ago this
this build was right
i don't know maybe if we like really
zoom in and try to enhance right here we
could see something about
actually you can see the uh game version
look at this nine eight three
four three eight
oh wait a second that might be a date
right there
oh i think that's a date oh no that's
the date for the engine version probably
427
should put it back in
april and then it just says dot two
who knows that may not be a date but
looks like it ate to me so then you've
got hair styles which
i mean if you go by the length of how
long this page can scroll
because we see what let's see 4 8 12 16
20. so we get 20 just right here and it
looks like they're not even a third of
the way down the page
so i think we're gonna get
a lot of good hairstyle options
and then you can set your hair color
right here at the top
the next tab over
complexion now mary this is another one
that i found very bizarre it's like okay
wait you've got skin color over here
under face wear but then you've got
complexion
and this is where you do freckles and
moles and scars i don't understand why
skin color is not also in with
complexion
just just a weird thing and who knows
that may be rearranged moved around for
final release this was a death centric
event
so
now the good news about all this is
chandler has actually commented on
what we saw in relation to the
um
what we saw in the relation to the
character creator chandler has commented
and said they they're going to show more
of that
and they're going to show us like the
full character creator which is i think
is great i think that'll be cool to see
then we have eyebrows
again like the titling is all weird here
i don't think this i'm gonna make a
prediction i don't think face wear
and i don't think eyebrows will be the
final title when the game ships because
like eyebrows
it's not just eyebrows here though
there's a lot more in this category than
just the eyebrows we got eye color we
got eyebrow color we got eyebrow shape
and then the last one uh the one yeah he
oh wait that was that was a different
tweet from chandler we'll talk about
that one too but then the tab that we
don't see
is the one that has the hogwarts crest
right here which a lot of people think
is where you're going to pick your house
that is where people think you will pick
your house maybe they have a little
questionnaire that you do
uh
i will say the faq one of the questions
that they have had on there for the
longest time is a question about
uh how will how will the sorting work
and it says you'll get to choose your
house at the start of hogwarts legacy
it seems like it's going to be a pretty
straightforward thing
um
so we'll see we'll see if they change
that or not
all right so i know i was i was going
through that and i missed some of the
comments here so let me scroll back up
and see
different voice options yeah i think i
think ellie i think that's almost
confirmed because
we hear
in this little clip that they shared
the protagonist's voice is different
so the clip that they shared at the
autodesk event we hear the protagonists
talk
and their voice is different than what
we've heard in the other trailers
so who knows how many options we'll have
but
uh i'm gryffindor logan
do we know if they're types of one
customer say nothing on ones yet swanson
that is one of the biggest requests
though for sure
is a
wand options one customization
background of the presets or that of
wizard cards yeah i do love the design
on the little backgrounds here
very much appears like a wizard card now
i also say it's kind of disappointing if
those are all the face options
but again we have no idea how finalized
this was
but people are going to be spending so
much time on this part right here
and again it doesn't appear that
ah let's see well we could probably
right here we can see that you can
scroll down more this doesn't have
anywhere to scroll down more so maybe
there's no more than this if this is all
we got then
probably no beards
unless
unless that was added later unless it
falls in a different category
yo
hi with another super chat thank you so
much again
with a question this time do you think
the harry potter cast are going to play
this game oh
i don't know how many of them are big
gamers
i feel like i remember uh
hearing about james and oliver oliver
phelps have done some uh
gaming stuff and i want to say tom
felton maybe has done some gaming stuff
that'd be fun though
that'd be super fun i know a lot of them
you know like to
were featured in the uh the back to
hogwarts
hbo
that was pretty fun to see all of them
again so
yeah that'd be fun though if they did
some kind of event where
or maybe if they even got them involved
in the promotion of the game that'd be
pretty cool
but thank you so much for the support
so yeah that's that's the character
creator stuff
and this sweet right here this this is
the one that chandler put out before a
couple weeks before the event i've seen
some excitement around our session at
the autodesk vision series and want to
set expectations it's a developer
focused event with cool insights into
our development process and animation
pipeline but don't expect a big new
trailer or other information
yo chandler
you guys did give us some other
information and we didn't get a big new
trailer but we got we got a little bit
we got a little bit
all right
i am going to
play the trailer or the new clip that
they showed us
i'm not going to do it with sound
because again
i don't think that we uh
i don't know where we might be fine
posting the sound too
but
so here is the new clip that they showed
oops hold on
and remember this is like the the final
do not judge the quality of the game
visually by this guys because you're
watching it
through my
let's see where did i get this video um
i think people people posted it all over
twitter and stuff so pretty sure was
twitter where i got it so twitter has
already compressed it down the different
rendering settings that they use when
they
set this up so visuals just ignore we're
just kind of watching it for the scene
which by the way
uh
take a look at the
customization here on the robe so it
looks like he's wearing some gloves he's
got a gold tie
and then this rope here somebody asked
me last time on stream they asked me why
are characters robes were different i
think it's just a customization thing i
think we're going to have that option
so this one looks much more closely to
the one that natsai is wearing except
for underneath you know he's wearing a
different colored tie
so let's watch this little scene here
which we have seen part of
in the gameplay trailer
so we get the hippogriff
they hide here
and then she asks the main character do
do we know the hippogriff
uh the name of this hippogriff is high
wing we see our character
that's what he says right here she's
like do you know this hippogriff or he
he says something like uh he's worried
about
high wing then she's like do you know
this hippogriff and he just turns and
gives
this strange
look and then she like gives him the
plan she's like okay here's what we're
gonna do
she's going to get uh some sort of
information and then
she wants us to help free the hippogriff
so she gets inside we get separated and
then maybe the biggest moment of all
this that people have been talking about
the screen shifts
and we see the character turn the
character is going to have to find
another way around and they show this
little wall
that can clearly be climbed i mean we
see games do this all the time like they
use the cut scene to kind of lead you
into here's where you need to go next
right down this path
uh and so we still don't even know if
like you can actually jump in hogwarts
legacy is it gonna be like one of the
old school uh like ocarina of time style
zelda's where you sort of run up
somewhere where you can jump and you
just push forward and they'll
automatically jump and grab on
or is it going to be more breath of the
wild zelda where you can jump anywhere
it's like such a weird question but it's
also one that's
very important to know like that will
have a huge impact on how the game is is
going to feel right can you jump or not
because if you can't that i mean that
makes a big difference
all right let's catch up with the
questions here
jenna love the new clips
pretty sure diagon alley will be in
because olive anders was shown in
screenshots of gameplay mike that's a
good point a lot of people bring that up
however it is not
the
diagon alley
ollivanders
it is actually the hogsmeade branch
of all of anders instead
it is the hogsmeade branch of
ollivanders
that that part is confirmed from seeing
the trailers we know that the olive
anders that we've seen is the hogsmead
branch now it's not confirmed whether or
not we'll see diagon alley
i just think the fact that they went it
clearly seems like they're focusing on
hogsmeade so maybe diagon alley would be
like a cut scene
but
it's not it's not we can't confirm it
just based on that though but i'm i'm
glad you brought that up because that's
still a comment that i see
quite a bit
let's see here characters wearing gloves
yeah
nightwing oh that threw me for a second
seeing nightwing i was thinking high
wings so high wing is the name of the
hippogriff that's another new piece that
we learned
any word on if we play years six and
seven i don't
no no official word i don't think so i
would be floored i would be absolutely
floored if we play through three years
if if
if that part ever leaks or they come out
and say yeah you're gonna go into year
six and seven
talk about being mind blown because then
if that happens
that confirms something very very big
that confirms dumbledore
that confirms dumbledore because if we
go into year seven dumbledore will be
showing up at hogwarts you can't you
can't not include him they just like
there's no way they could get around
that so he's 100 going to be in if we go
to year seven i think
they did us started us at year five to
leave it open for the possibility of
sequels i think it's going to be just
your five
is again just my guess just my guess
physical combat a thing here can i plant
a goblet across a dungeon
uh that's i don't think there's going to
be any sort of melee
but who knows right who knows trying to
think if we ever saw
oh man if we ever saw any wizards who
used like a melee
magic hybrid
i guess the closest thing would be
oh man i guess the closest thing would
be like
like fenrir but i feel like that's a
terrible comparison because he was a
werewolf
yeah i don't know i feel like i'm gonna
say no it would be my guess i think it's
gonna be just uh
just magic for for combat
go to hogsmeade after customizing your
character
see that's the thing i think
actually i just saw that rossi posted
the
timeline of events earlier and i didn't
get to comment on it
by the way if any of you are getting uh
i see a couple of comments getting um
cleared out by the auto mod um it might
be detecting like a link or
i think i have a pretty clean filter set
up for language because i like to keep
it family friendly
so uh if you're trying to type something
and it keeps getting kicked out it's not
me manually doing it so
it might be one of those two things i
know it won't accept links so if there's
a link you want me to check out you'll
just have to to let me know where to go
look for it let me see that if i can
find that post from jay rossi i think
it's been a while back
talking about the timeline of events
because i know that uh
expecto go had a great video on this
couple months back yeah so the timeline
of events rossi says would be gringotts
so that's the scene with uh with fig the
main character
maybe we do start at diagonal you guys
because that would make so much sense
like maybe that's the start of the game
maybe diagon alley we show up at diagon
alley
we're getting our supplies that's when
we ch when we create our character oh
that'd be awesome then we have the the
gringotts scene because we see our
character
then ross is saying train then flying
coach then hogwarts see i think
i don't think we're gonna ride on the
train
and if you think about the way it worked
and the movies kind of changed this up
from the book
because in the book harry gets his
supplies
and then there's like a there's like a
he doesn't immediately go to school like
he does in the movies
um in the movies it's like hagrid's
there haggard leaves him and then it's
like it's time to go
um
hagrid takes him to
to uh platform nine and three quarters
so i feel like i feel like the hogwarts
express is going to get cut out
i feel like the the flying carriage
maybe we're we're literally starting
like not only are we starting late as a
fifth year but we're also like arriving
late in the we're getting there like
just for the feast
dude maybe we missed the hogwarts
express because of what happens with the
goblins
just saying
the goblins attack while we're there
maybe that throws off our timing so
fig's like oh i'm gonna have to you know
set up this
stagecoach to come and pick us up
instead that's when we get the cut scene
of like dude look at this here's the
here's the rebellion we see the daily
prophet
then we get the scene of uh this so the
first trailer remember how it starts how
the carriage flies in hogwarts is
already it's already evening we fly in
and then we immediately go in for the
opening feast
i think that is kind of the timeline for
how the game will start but now as i as
i started saying that aloud though i
think uh diagon alley would be it'd be a
perfect like tutorial area man
it would be so good
so good
all right let me scroll back down
because i'm sure you guys have had some
uh
comments as well
surname will be set but our first name
could be anything we want
uh let me think about that one first
name we absolutely get to choose first
name 100 percent
last name
i shouldn't say 100 i'll say 99
last name i don't know i kind of feel
like they would they would
yeah it would it would make more sense
because they would they're probably
going to have dialogue programmed of
characters saying our last name
right
butter
weasley
granger
gotta have that right ooh bellatrix is
dagger that's a good example that's a
good example of like the melee of a
character actually using something other
than
because malfoy has the uh
the thing on his cane and he pulls it
out and
at the end of chamber
and he goes at harry and i never could
understand what he was saying there i
mean it almost sounds like he's
does he pull out a knife or does he pull
out the wand no he pulls out the wand
and then he just like the way he's
holding it almost looks like he's
holding some sort of dagger
always sounded to me like he was about
to say vada kadara it's like wait what
oh
let's see here i think we'd be able to
go customize where the magical beasts go
and the room of requirements how the
rooms look it certainly seems like it
it certainly seems like it that was
another part in that trailer that blew
me away did not expect that
the whole menagerie for magical beast
that blew my mind
diagon alley yeah if it's not in that
would be a fun dlc location if they uh
had some sort of story element to go
around it
only thing you want is slice of life
things let me go to classes whenever i
want breakfast dinner just exist live
here charles sounds like you might want
more of an mmo style game but who knows
maybe they'll have elements of that here
maybe they'll have elements
talk about the delay sorry if you
answered that already uh we did we
talked about the delay in the beginning
this this vod will be going up
um it goes up immediately after but it
takes it a while to fully for youtube to
fully compress it and everything
but we did talk about that in the
beginning um just just rumor still for
now nothing confirmed
my personal guess i i posted this on
twitter as well
i wouldn't be shocked by another delay
uh if we do get a delay i think it will
be a short one so like a january
february
is my guess
that's that's a very quick summary we we
dove in a lot more
uh deep than that
mark don't think diagon alley is in yeah
my gut says it's not either but as i was
saying like the timeline i'm like oh
it'd be perfect if that's what we
started
imagine if our character is a potter
yeah i don't think they're going there
peverell maybe a peverell though
starting to imagine our character
dreaming of merlin morgana as we wake up
in an orphanage ooh
was it was it confirmed nightwing to be
a vodakadavra the only thing he can
i remember hearing that now that you
mentioned it oh my goodness i'd totally
forgot about that though
but well that's what it sounded like to
me jason it sounded like you were saying
monsta gaga welcome thank you so much
for subscribing
lucius malfoy is terrible would you love
it yeah he does have a pretty uh
cool design for the wand
dual since controllers features will
work on pc rule of eternity that's a
question i would love to know the answer
to
and i don't know that there's
i haven't played
a ps5
first party game on pc i haven't played
like horizon or days gone
but the thing at the end they haven't
brought i don't think they've brought
any ps5
games yet to pc have they
is your eternal out on pc return if
return is out on pc that would be a good
one to test because it has a lot of dual
sense features but like god of war and
the first horizon those were ps4 games
so i don't know that there's anything to
compare to yet my gut instinct is no
i i think i could see them lock being
like hey you want those features you got
to play on ps5 but it'd be cool if they
did i think it'd be cool if they did
ran uh ranton's reaction to hogwarts
legacy on his second channel is this
like uh is that a reaction to
[Music]
the gameplay trailer or the first
trailer
don't think us being a dark wizard will
affect the story just
the story gameplay some way you know
spider-man is out on pc but that that
was also a ps4 game
yeah unless uh i don't think they
brought mile well wait miles miles
morales this is a ps4 game two
if anybody has played any of these
playstation games and knows whether or
not the duel sense
because none of those games have
exclusive dual since features because
they were also on ps4
i'm pretty sure about that pretty sure
oh it's a reaction to the state of play
gotcha
yo that's right teal click that like
button
where do i see how many
oh there we go
125 likes let's go let's push that to
150.
oh see mary here's here's the mistake i
made last time that remember how it
started showing ads like right as i was
signing off
so i
whenever you live stream on youtube i've
done a lot of live streaming on twitch
youtube i've only done this is my second
one
whenever you go into like this so i've
got my obs where i have all the streams
set up but then youtube has this other
area
that
i don't really even know what you would
call it it's just like sort of a where
you can monitor the stream so it tells
you like viewers that making sure it's
set to public
title that sort of thing
and so that's where i saw how many likes
we had yo let's go up to 132
but then when i go to that page there's
this big blue pop-up on kind of the top
right it says now would be a good time
to insert ads
and so i think if you click the button
it inserts the ad i'm just going to
click close this time
creators earn more money inserting ads
the more viewers are watching give it a
try i'm just going to hit close
i love that youtube gives you that
option
hopefully i don't know if it
automatically runs i know it'll
automatically run them when you
like watch the vod
that's something i always kind of annoys
me about twitch is that you don't have
like it the ads are forced like you
don't have any kind of control over
whether or not they run
but i digress i digress
bully with a harry potter hey a lot of
people have said they would love to see
that
i've never played bully but i've heard
so many good things
uh luke says spider-man on pc is the
remaster that's yeah so it does feature
the duels features
probably safer to do some research yeah
yeah
before i before i officially say that's
that's definite yeah and and even if it
i was just trying to think if there was
any kind of precedent for it
um of them like intentionally leaving it
out you know
but hopefully not hopefully not
white wolf thank you so much
little man we'll probably be up a couple
times tonight great stream
hey thank you so much for stopping by
dude good luck with the little one
i know when they're it sounds like
they're young enough to where you have
the uh
you never know when you're gonna be
waking up in the night
don't worry that that gets a lot better
that gets a lot better
mine are eight and four now
and i gotta say they've always been very
good sleepers but now i mean
pretty they go go to bed around 8 8 30
and then usually we're good till like 7
a.m sometimes they even sleep past that
but
like that right there
i would sleep much later every day if i
could but
that's a good window right there
bull is your favorite game i'm streaming
with podcast yes i will be on with
podcast now tomorrow
he's doing a live show
um
over on his channel yeah so i'll be
joining him for that
talking more hogwarts legacy
talking lots more hogwarts legacy
let my kids play hogwarts legacy oh good
uh
my youngest wouldn't care yet and my
oldest we haven't read the series to him
yet
um it depends it depends i guess on how
uh how dark it goes with some things
yeah i hadn't really thought about that
though
all right let's talk about a few more
things
i love the questions though keep coming
you guys uh
have always have lots of good questions
there were a couple more screenshots
that i wanted to talk about from the
autodesk then we'll do a few more
questions and then we'll uh
we'll see if there's been any other big
news
and then wrap it up um so here's one i
want to talk about
i want your interaction on this one i
want to hear your theories this is one
that i found and just
immediately i threw this arrow and
circled it and sent it to james on
twitter
i was like dude
what the heck
what the heck
so just give people some context here
this is a little mannequin so they were
showing off some of their options for
um as they as they build their
characters you know so we already talked
about this a little bit when we had
professor ronin up on screen
but then in this shot the guy clicks on
robe right here
and very quickly it goes to like a
different screen i think he might
maybe he picks a robe or something but
it jumps to another screen so you don't
really see much after but he clicks on
robe right here so this category
he clicks on this category and then we
get this drop down here
now here's where we're delving into
territory that like
unless you're a game developer out there
we're delving into areas that we really
don't know a whole lot about but we see
we see names and we see things that we
recognize so of course we gotta
speculate right
so the first one we have a
am
ghost sir patrick delaney podmore
dynamics
so the part that i think is weird is
that this falls under robe
because this like does i mean this
doesn't sound like a robe to me
sir patrick delaney podmore if you guys
don't know was the leader of the
headless hunt
and we also have that shot in the
trailer where it seems like our
character and nearly headless nick could
be going to a death day party because
nearly headless snake is talking about
once again my quest to join the headless
hunt has been denied
then we have this uh other character
carriage driver dynamics so i don't know
if this is like some sort of behavior
i do think it would be cool if like the
am is in reference to like they only
appear in the day
in the daytime hours
or under this certain dynamic maybe
oh by the way i just got an alert on my
phone there is a lightning and storms in
my area so hopefully things won't cut
out hopefully we'll be good but uh if
things suddenly go out you'll know what
happened
then we have so now with the the little
prefix changes here mcmb portrait armor
mcmb professor black
mcmbh dark wizard captain dynamics mcmbh
deathly hallows and then again
mcmbh professor black so this one this
professor black is just the cmb this one
is the cmbh i've heard some uh i was
talking to some folks on reddit about
this some were saying that maybe the
mcmb stands for
mannequin
and then
oh wait what do we say character
mannequin bust
so we have character mannequin mannequin
bust here maybe it's something to do
with that
and then we have some that are clearly
labeled as robes beasts
herbology zero one
arcane jacket zero one astronomy beast
coat and then who knows what else down
there
who knows what else
[Music]
why have we not talked about the ghost
at the top oh you sent that a while ago
nightwing you'll have to remind me to
remind me what uh
are you talking about a different shot
there i can go back to it
you're a wizard easter egg or developer
test kit yo
rion ryan agrius thank you so much for
the sub welcome welcome
you're a wizard
two games to play welcome thank you for
the sub as well
ah only seven months white wolf said
gotcha
oh yeah the the battle of hogwarts yes
we gotta get to that one too
we gotta get i got another screenshot
with that one on there
um
i think it's fun uh honestly i think
it's a fun easter egg cosmetic purposes
type of deal
that's sort of where i'm at too i think
it might be like an emblem that we can
get like on our clothing
like on our robe
i don't think it's the invisibility
cloak as a lot of people have been
saying i don't think it's that
i could see it being some sort of
visual that we'll we'll be able to wear
but then if we can wear it then i'm like
okay well then does that is there some
point of the story where
it's it's it's like they're mentioned or
there's like there's rumors of a wizard
having this unbeatable wand
or there there's rumors of
this uh this stone that's like bringing
people oh my gosh talk about mind blown
what if somebody has the stone and
they're like try
yo where's james
j rossi dude what if somebody has the
resurrection stone
and they're trying to use it to bring
back merlin or morgana
yo
i'm gonna have to reread that story
in tales of beatle the bard
there is a story about
the resurrection stone
being used and how it like doesn't go at
all how the person expected
because they're basically not
they're not really themselves
um and then of course we see when harry
uses the resurrection stone how it
how the dead manifests themselves for
him
uh man i'm gonna have to brush up on
that and send that send that to james be
like all right time for you to add that
to your theory
high iq warrior reference to wizards who
know the lore of the deathly hallows and
hunt them like grindelwald and
dumbledore could also be an easter egg
to the deathly hallows games oh my gosh
uh yeah like we see um
we see luna's dad
xenophilius
who actually wears the mark of the
deathly hallows so this is this is an
in-world thing it could be something
that they put in and it doesn't have to
have some other they don't need a ton of
other things explaining it it could
stand on the lore that we already have
uh somebody else said maybe the main
characters related to one of the
hogwarts founders possible possible
wonder where this background is that's a
good question too don't want depth of
the cables in the game feel too much
like a retread yeah i could i could see
that
i think it'd be better if it was just
like a more subtle thing you know like
the main story's not all about it
i do like my i do like my resurrection
stone idea though i do like my
resurrection stone
hnr i'm a
developer
it's just a robe with the deadly yellow
symbol
okay
what do you think we would pick up from
looting
i like that question because we know
that looting is confirmed in the game uh
i think the most obvious like easiest
one is potion ingredients
potion ingredients for sure
um maybe every now and then you come
across wizarding artifacts probably
money as well
so
galleons sickles and canuts
look it up guys look it up on wizarding
world the k is not silent
i talk about this any chance i get
the k is actually not silent
all this is fun to talk about i hope
we're not hyping it too much only for it
to not be not to be in the game yeah
that hey fair point on that grey rob
for sure fair point just because we saw
all this just because this is 100
confirmed by avalanche doesn't mean it's
100 confirmed to be in the final game i
put out a tweet about that and also
included that in my video a little
disclaimer of like hey guys some of the
stuff they're seeing this was an inside
look this was a behind-the-scenes look
it's not a guarantee
that
m hat pointy hat that this hat right
here it's not a guarantee it's gonna be
in the game
now some of the other things like the
professors
i think there are some things that we
can feel pretty confident about
december 6
we'll see i hope so i hope it hits
december 6. i want to get into detention
oh man if this game is delayed i've lost
all hope no we have to we have to keep
hope
he talked about that at the end of order
gotcha
when harry was yelling at
dumbledore h could mean hooded
oh yeah maybe that means that they have
the hood pulled up
deathly hallows hood what would a
deathly hallows hood look like
choose a bad wizard then we start the
battle yeah okay let's talk you guys you
guys can you want to talk about the
battle stuff i can tell
so let me pull up my other screenshot
here
let us see
i think it's this one
is this the one
uh
no this is not the one
it's this one
so yeah just like we had that drop down
menu you guys saw before this is another
drop down menu that we see
house elf already knew those were in the
game howler
that's pretty cool hope they're in the
final game
in furious
we know inferior in we see them in the
uh
actually in the gameplay mannequin
that'd be like a fun easter egg right if
you can play as the mannequin something
you unlock at the end marketing only
character
named customizable enemy oh wait like
named customizable enemy
interesting i don't know what to make of
that other character pacifist player
player fight club ally portrait
character prefect professor professor
battle of hogwarts a professor battle of
hogwarts b professor battle of hogwarts
c
i mean
i don't know guys i don't know because
this stuff's kind of all over the board
like we have some things that are pretty
clearly things we know how self howler
and furious yeah we know what those are
then you have like pacifist like is that
a trophy or something
if you go through the game without
harming anyone
fabian a thank you for the sub welcome
and then you just have something that's
player
professor battle of hogwarts dude what
if we like tr nah i don't want to do any
time travel man i was about to start
throwing out a time travel theory where
we travel to the battle of hogwarts with
voldemort
nah
i'm just not a fan of time travel
don't get me started on cursed child
prisoner of azkaban like that's about as
much like the way they handle time
travel i feel like was perfect there
it was it was very contained it was very
clear what the rules and limitations are
when it starts getting much more than
that it's it's kind of annoying to me
[Music]
how do you find money
i think we will get money like maybe we
do find it from like looting the the
chests and stuff but i bet we also get
it for completing missions for npcs
like those npcs that we meet around the
world that they show
scattered
around the hogwarts area
i think we'll earn money for uh
helping them out
rossi's thinks the cultists could want
to bring back more ghana and the return
of ancient magic has do with her merlin
wants to hide and protect yeah i think
merlin would definitely be on the
on the good side if it breaks down to
like a good evil thing
what if the name customizable enemy is a
is a family relative of ours
oh and it's like you're it's like based
on
our character's last name
yeah that'd be interesting
pacifist probably characters that don't
fight when you attack them oh yeah like
it's programmed to uh
yeah that's a good that's a good that's
a good one too
player fight club ally
i love that they have something called
fight club
is that gonna be dueling
hey good night feathers thanks so much
for stopping by and hanging out
oh my gosh cursed child
i've not seeing it live i'll say that
i've heard that live it's actually a
really fun play
and i would probably love it i would
probably enjoy it
if they didn't literally put on the book
that it's the eighth
the eighth book get out of here with
that
get out of here with that come on
oh so many story problems with it as a
play like just as a fun like hey this is
a fan fictiony sort of thing somebody
like a what if i'm i'm all good with it
but don't tell me this is like the
actual canon don't do it to me no
too obvious merlin uh merlin's the
villain
see i don't think
i don't think these ancient wizards are
going to be the villain because unless
it's some sort of weird thing with
either ghost the resurrection stone i
don't think it's horcruxes because the
first person to create the horcrux was
um oh gosh what was that dude's name
i'm forgetting the name of the dude that
um
no it's not crisp and cronk
let me look it up here
i was trying not to look it up
i was trying to remember it without
looking it up but
first horcrux
herpo the foul that's right there was a
leak that i think was
most likely false but there was a leak
probably i don't know a year or so ago
that
purpo the foul was going to be the main
villain and that he actually did succeed
in making one of the first horcruxes
i don't know we shall see we shall see
you don't talk yeah you don't talk about
wizard fight club no no no no
no no no no
anything from dueling besides experience
maybe the team with the most dueling
seeing cursed child live on the 17th
nice ezra i
i mean i bet i bet you'll really enjoy
the show i bet as a show i bet it's
awesome i really
i i would like to see it i just have
story
story problems with it
love a dlc that takes place in the
summer that'd be cool
that'd be cool
hallbury
thank you so much for subbing to the
channel welcome
oh dude let's see how many likes how
many likes did we get up to
146 four people we need four people to
smash that like button
get it up to the 150.
come on come on you guys got this
thumbs up thumbs up underneath
we're 146 right now let's see let's see
see i gotta come up with an incentive
now i gotta take some inspiration from
my buddy james because james if he had
certain number of likes you know you're
getting a pureet there we go 149.
we got 149
and there it is 150 let's go
let's see what can i what's something
fun i can do here
uh let's see do you have anything
anything harry potter related in the
room i could show off or we could talk
about
oh geez let's see
oh man we gotta do something
i need to put something potter related
back on the
my shelf that i have back there
because as it is right now it's um
i have uh metroid things on there right
now
but yeah thank you guys so much for the
support oh man we blew past it dude
i looked we were 150 and then i looked
away and looked back now we're at 170
let's go
oh man if merlin is the actual villain
and his intentions are not revealed
until late game
breakdance at 150 oh my gosh i would
show my dog she is usually in here with
me but i yeah she's not in here my wife
took her upstairs before uh before i
started streaming tonight
but yeah for those of you who haven't
seen before my dog is a westie named
luna
you guys can probably figure out where
the name came from
can probably figure out
import faces
i'm gonna say no unless maybe like
the pc version there might be a way like
with mods somehow
i feel like that's a thing that some
sports games tried
when the console makers first started
putting out
like the i toy and the uh you know the
camera and the xbox camera and all that
i feel like that is things that some of
the big sports
video game makers tried and it never
really seemed to take off i don't know
if they still do it or not in those
games
i have no idea
oh i got a okay here's a fun one
something i can show you guys for uh
to celebrate the 172 likes let me see
here one second
all right it's literally like the one
harry potter thing that i
remembered that i had
in the room
so on our
on uh
on the channel we've been live streaming
not live streaming we've been um doing
let's plays of
this game right here check out that
blast from the past
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
on the nintendo gamecube
and look at this man remember this icon
right here it actually had a special uh
you could link it up
with the game boy advance version and
there was something
i don't remember what it was you could
unlock but there was something extra
yeah if you look on the back here
oh i've got the
i've got the auto focus off so you guys
may not it's not going to autofocus for
you but
the dementors are coming play as harry
ron and hermione face the demon tools
oh wait i forgot and right here it says
and this time harry needs his friends so
that was a big deal when this one came
out
that they uh it wasn't just harry this
time you actually started
interacting and actually playing as
ron and hermione in certain parts of the
game as well
for information on this specific product
visit harry potter.ea.com
for more information on harry potter
visit harry potter.com
fly buckbeak
that was a pretty cool feature that they
added i'm gonna see if that website
still exists
the the harry potter ea one
let's try to find out together you guys
harry potter
oh my gosh i can't type
is that what it was
harry potter.ea.com
does it still exist
i'm looking up right now i'll pull it up
if it works so far no luck
oh come on
i feel like i've went to this site
before and i thought it was still up
because they had like references to the
old games but no
not working
and it was worth a shot right it's worth
a shot
all right let's see if you got any final
questions guys go ahead and uh send them
now i'll try to get to as many as i can
before we hop off here
been
another
excuse me that came out of nowhere
oh man they get they gave me chills too
oh we got niko spoiling assassin's creed
valhalla come on mate
don't be spoiling games
i'm sure it was accidental
oh yeah did you see that did you catch
that nightwing
i didn't know if morgana would be large
enough to show up there yeah from uh
persona 5. morgana is on the shelf as
well
talking about a completely different
morgana
uh the pottermore wand that yours is
hawthorne with a unicorn core
so mine is
uh let's see we're done with that
and i believe we're done with that
mine is i know it's phoenix core
and i think it's beechwood
i believe
yeah beach
so mine is beechwood with a phoenix core
12 and 1 4 with unbending flexibility
lawn chooses the wizard mr potter
so the true match for a beach wand will
be if young why is beyond his or her
years
why thank you and if full grown uh i
guess i'm full grown
rich and understanding and experienced
beach bonds perform very weakly for the
narrow minded and intolerant such
wizards and witches have obtained of
each one without having been suitably
matched
yet coveting this most desirable richly
hued and highly prized wand wood have
often presented themselves at the homes
of learned wand makers such as myself
demanding to know the reason for their
handsome wands lack of power when
properly matched the beach wand is
capable of a subtlety and artistry
rarely seen in any other wood hence its
lustrous reputation dude i love how they
make all the ones just sound so
incredibly awesome
like i read that and i'm like yes dude
let's go
i don't think i've i don't know if i've
ever read the un unbending flexibility
um oh that one really doesn't have a
lengthy description on it
denotes the degree of adaptability and
willingness to change possessed by the
wand and owner pair although again this
factor ought not to be considered
separately from the wand
wood core in length nor of the owner's
life experiences style of magic all of
which will combine to make the wine in
question unique
how far the world of gaming have come
yeah it's uh it's amazing what games can
do now i did see that about the hogwarts
legacy or not hogwarts legacy but
hogwarts created in dreams blew my mind
blew my mind
hey francie thank you so much for the
sub welcome
do the nba games still allow that that's
pretty cool though if they do that yeah
i knew they had i knew the sports games
kayla kayla tara thank you for the sub
as well
i remember seeing a lot of the sports
games doing that so that's pretty cool
yo you like the hat car car thank you
very much
it is uh one of the first
merch items that i have released
it's actually available in the shop and
if you want to check it out it's uh the
shop should show up below my
actually let me see where does it show
up on the
when we're live streaming
but right now we just have a there's
like a couple of shirts in there
let's see a couple of shirts like a mug
oh i don't think it shows up on the live
stream
oh that's kind of annoying
let me find a link for you guys just if
you're curious
because we are going to be having some
pretty cool
that's how we started off the stream i
showed everybody some of the pretty
pretty slick stuff we're going to be
having
very very soon which
may or may not involve our
the wizard we've been talking a lot
about our buddy merlin himself
our buddy merlin
and some other uh things inspired
by the world of magic
okay here we go let's see view
okay it's retrorec and tour
it's kind of a weird link but
right
here
dude what if it doesn't let me to post
what if it didn't let me post a link
okay good i think it worked but yeah on
most of my videos you should actually
see the store below the video like um
but for whatever reason it doesn't look
like it shows up on live streams but
yeah keep an eye on that because i'll
announce it on twitter and everything
we'll talk about in live stream when i
start adding some more items uh but yeah
it's gonna be fun thank you though i
love this hat i it's kind of become like
my
my staple i try to wear it every stream
and in a lot of my videos as well
because i have a lot of a lot of the
sports teams that i like are navy blue
color so i have a ton of navy blue hats
but i didn't have a
any just like solid black hats
all right let's see hufflepuff saint
bernard
laurel one unicorn hair for king of the
frogs nice
could the game release september 1st
ryan asks definitely not we might get a
release date on september 1st but they
have said holiday 2022
is the last official word that's what
they're targeting so it's definitely not
going to come out september 1st got all
the games for ps2 and ps3 except for
deathly house part 2.
oh that'd be fun like easter eggs and
cheats that you unlock at the end of the
game
like to be a gryffindor because of the
sword
since my wand is hawthorne wasn't
dumbledore's wand made of hawthorne
i think they have on the site like
oh yeah let's see what
oh wait dumbledore it just talks about
him having the
the elder wand
but what did dumbledore
the wiki says
was of an unknown length wood core and
material
huh
interesting
that's what the wiki says i don't know
feel the sword of gryffindor could be
important maybe
maybe i mean it would be cool if
something with the sword of gryffindor
happened in this game
because we know it's goblin made and
goblin are gonna goblins are gonna play
a big big role
oh tara like t-e-r-r-a but my name is
kayla oh nice okay gotcha kayla tara
but you go by kayla cool nice well thank
you for uh stopping by and hanging out
not even a harry potter fan but can't
wait for this game i've heard that from
a lot of people
[Music]
i heard it from a lot of people
hope there's a new game plus i hope so
for sure
hope so for sure
that feels like something that they
definitely need to have gryffindor with
a hound patronus nice
what's going on here any new news uh we
just got rap kind of wrapped up talking
about the autodesk session
and yo dark thank you for subscribing as
well appreciate that
we talked about the autodesk that's
probably the biggest piece of of news is
everything that came out with the
autodesk and then there continue to be
rumor swirling of a delay
so that's that's what we talked about
and i think those rumors are gonna keep
happening until until they put a date on
it you know and apparently with uh
midnight suns doing its thing even after
you put a date on it
even a date that's so close it's still
not official until until like it goes
gold and the game is shipped
it's crazy
but that's that's kind of the
environment we're in right now
uh you could definitely be bright
inspector i just kind of did a quick
search and that's what it popped up on
the uh
popped up on the hp wiki
just doing a search to see if hawthorne
showed up anywhere on the page
just did the test harry potter fan club
ravenclaw nice patronus dolphin wand is
ebony
slytherin with a sphynx cat patronus
what does the ebony wand do um if you
did the test on the wizarding world
there should be a thing where you can
click on your the wand wood and it'll
kind of give you the
description of it
yo nico's still here hanging out nice
nice
very cool
still think one of the dungeons i think
godric's hollow where godric's braided
oh my gosh that'd be so cool
that'd be so cool
i would love that
yeah because uh
we know there's a cairn a cairn dungeon
and cairns are typically used to mark
graves
and we don't know if it's going to be
called cairn dungeon in the in the game
but that is what they were referring to
it internally we know that from some of
the uh
resumes and things that they didn't even
really leak it was just stuff that was
posted and available online by people
who had worked on the game
yep
all right let me see here
oh my gosh we're at two
i just checked the clock earlier and i
was like oh we're we're almost at two
hours i'll probably wrap up around then
and now we're almost at two and a half
hours
so it's a good thing that it goes by
fast you know means uh means we're
having a good time so hopefully things
went by fast for you guys as well
um what's going on rest of the week so
definitely gonna have at least one more
one video hitting this week i'm gonna
try and get two out
i'm working on some um
special thing let's just say that i
can't i can't quite talk about just yet
but i've got some special stuff keep an
eye out i can say this keep an eye out
for some giveaways
gonna be doing some upcoming giveaways
on
the channel very soon very very soon so
keep it on twitter at retrorecontour and
also of course on the youtube videos as
well
um also i'm gonna be giving these
wallpapers away very soon i'm still kind
of finalizing so the wallpaper you see
right here i'm gonna give away the files
for those put those up on
i'll probably link it on twitter or like
um
email it out to people
something like that so that's coming up
tomorrow night i'm going to be on with
uh alex a podcast now he invited me to
be on his live show to talk hogwarts
legacy
so if you guys uh you're gonna we're
gonna have wizarding with day tomorrow
with james
he does his thing every every uh
wednesday afternoon slash evening and
then uh you'll have have time to get it
get a snack get a bathroom break in
between and then you can hop over and
and watch alex and i talk more hogwarts
legacy so we'll see what tomorrow brings
maybe there's going to be some news that
pops out tomorrow we'll see
but guys thank you so much for hanging
out man the support has once again been
crazy i'm gonna try and keep this a
regular staple every tuesday i'm gonna
i'm gonna try to hit it we did one last
tuesday we're gonna do one again this
tuesday just an amazing
amazing turnout uh we ended up hitting
180 likes we were over 200 viewers at
one point so thank you guys so much for
the support and love we're gonna keep
bringing you the all the new series and
discussion relating to hogwarts legacy
um and probably gonna be some more games
that we're covering on the channel soon
as well darth webbon
i love oh my gosh i love that name
darth webin
thank you so much for subscribing to the
channel
caleb been subscribed to alex for a
while nice yeah alex was like one of the
first
when i first started looking up hogwarts
legacy
videos and content he was like one of
the first people that i came across so
love the videos hey thank you so much
appreciate it guys thank you all so much
for hanging out i gotta get a little
outro video here we need to come up with
some kind of outro and i need to i need
to work on the intro video too because
i've got the old one but i don't know
what i want to do yet
i don't know what i want to do for the
kind of the intro countdown so i gotta i
got to do some brainstorming on that if
you have any ideas hit me up on twitter
at retrorecontour but hope you all have
a fantastic rest of your week
and as always
thank you all so much for watching
i will talk to you again